jenkins get in here uh sir morbius has  been a colossal flop i need to hear some  good news well sir morbius appears to be  gaining traction on the internet really  it's been trending for the past five  days on twitter with everyone sharing  the famous catchphrase it's morbid time  does he actually say that in the movie i  didn't see it  me neither the internet is jumping on  the morbi train sharing relatable memes  and you know making fun of the movie let  me understand you're saying morbius is  the number one movie in america no it's  just become a meme you know because it's  bad so you're saying they want more oh  god bs no get jared leto on the phone  right now